[MUSIC PLAYING]
DINO CHIESA: Hi, Dino here.
I'm with Apigee,
and I help people
use APIs to build their
digital businesses.
Welcome to your
Apigee Edge trial.
With Apigee, you'll be
able to securely expose
bare APIs with API
keys or OAuth or JWT,
modernize existing
SOAP services,
publish your APIs to developers
through your own custom API
portal, and get
visibility into usage
of your APIs via API analytics.
All of that is available to
you when you manage your APIs
with Apigee Edge.
Listen, APIs are the foundation
for digital businesses
large and small, and
with Apigee, you're
ready to harness that
potential for yourself.
In upcoming videos,
we'll get hands-on
and I'll show you how
to wrap management
around your APIs in minutes.
Before we do that,
let's cover some basics.
The key concept enabling the API
management goodness in Apigee
Edge is the API proxy.
A proxy is a wrapper
for your actual service.
Clients, instead of calling
your API endpoint directly,
call the API proxy, and the API
proxy calls your existing API.
You may be thinking,
why the extra hop?
Why use one extra moving part?
Well, I'll tell you.
The API proxy provides
the way to plug
in an application-independent
mechanism for you
to specify consistent management
rules and policies that
apply to all of your APIs.
Your APIs might be
a mix of services,
lacking consistency with respect
to security, or data model,
or even URL design,
and an API proxy
allows you to build
a coherent facade
around those various endpoints.
Or maybe all of your APIs are
clean, new implementations,
so you don't need a proxy
to enforce consistency,
but you will still want an
API proxy to handle things
like OAuth token verification
or caching, routing,
rate limiting, and
analytics and reporting.
Apigee can provide all
of that with no coding
and no modification of
your existing services.
So that's API management.
Apigee Edge lets you easily
add management to any API.
Ready to get started?
In the next video, we'll
dive into the first step
in using Apigee, creating
your first proxy.
Until next time,
keep it digital.
[MUSIC PLAYING]